[Music]
pictures on 3d cups have depth and
appear to move depending on the angle
you view them it's a neat trick made
possible by a technology known as
lenticular printing a sheet of tiny
plastic lenses is applied to interlaced
images creating a kind of graphic magic
to entertain you a 3d cup pulls the eye
viewed from different angles
the artwork seems to come to life it's
all a carefully crafted illusion making
3d cups starts with clear plastic
pellets an extruder machine melts the
pellets to a semi-liquid consistency an
engraving cylinder forms it into rows of
tiny convex lenses water chilled
cylinders cooled the sheet of lenses
this solidifies the plastic then it
gauge measures the lenses thickness a
blower device dissipate static an inkjet
printer prints information on the edge
this indicates the optical resolution of
the lenses the type of plastic and the
lot number then a rotary blade cuts the
plastic into sheets the sheets land in a
neat stack
[Music]
to confirm their size and alignment and
inspector views them against a pitch
test pattern another inspector magnifies
a sample 100 times and measures the
thickness of the lenses to thin or thick
and the lens display won't focus with
the lens strip clamped at both ends the
machine pulls it from the top how far it
stretches until it breaks is a measure
of its strength meanwhile a team designs
and edit scenes on a computer designers
copy the scene divided into very narrow
strips and then interlace the strips
next the strips are combined into a
2-dimensional digital file designers now
run test copies known as proofs this
process tests sheets of colored plastic
film which will serve as ink the
technician layers the colored film in a
cartridge with muslin paper
[Music]
next the cartridge is placed in the
printer which creates the proofs the
designer transfers them to an
illuminated work surface and confirms
that the images line up with the plastic
lenses once the print plates are made an
operator loads them into the printer
a suctioning arm feeds the lenticular
plastic sheets into the printer reverse
side up in this position the images will
be printed on the smooth side of the
plastic rotating cylinders transfer ink
from the printing plates to the sheets
one color at a time
this system prints several different 3d
cup images on each lenticular plastic
sheet the press ejects and stacks the
printed sheets the 3d printed sheets now
head into a laminator it applies a white
film to the artwork this film will
protect the 3d images during the cup
molding process next the sheets are cut
into cup sized labels placed on an
illuminated table and inspected for any
visual flaws once approved the designer
clears the labels to be formed two
plastic cups next an operator loads the
stacks of 3d labels into the cup forming
machine this machine will process four
different labels on two cups at once
each with a different 3d image
a robot with suction grippers picks up
the labels one at a time and transfers
them to cup shaped mandrels the mandrel
inserts the 3d label into the mold of a
cup molten polypropylene flows into the
mold and as it solidifies and becomes a
cup the 3d label fuses to it together
robots retrieve the 3d cups and stack
them on their sides to await final
inspection then they're packaged for
shipment 3d cups are no ordinary
beverage container rather they're a fun
visual experience for any type of
consumer